I'm not that smart that I can see 50
years ahead and and say which technology
is going to be the most efficient but
ultimately I don't think anyone can ask
the soul of people and they'll say solar
panels are great ask the wind turbine
people and they say wind turbines are
great but the point is we should be
funding all of those possibly great
alternatives and it's okay that most of
them are going to fail because the ones
that won't fail are the ones that are
going to be powering the rest of the
21st century if we look at potential
from an engineering point of view it's
very clearly solar that has the greatest
potential it could actually cover the
entire energy consumption of the world
from just one hour of sunshine on this
planet or to put it differently if we
put out the current effectiveness of
solar panels on just two point six
percent of the air the Sahara we could
cover the entire world energy
consumption now of course we wouldn't do
that because we want it different places
and we also have the question of storage
and there's a lot of other issues that
we need to fix most of which is the
economic point that solar panels is
still about 10 times as expensive as
fossil fuels and that leads us to the
second point which of these many
different possible green technologies
are the most sustainable in the long run
economically that's a very different
question and unfortunately not one that
I know the answer to and I don't think
anyone knows we can't predict what is
going to become of the effectiveness
over the next 50 years that's why we
should be investing in research and
development on all of these different
technologies we don't know which one is
going to win if you will but that's okay
because some of them vote will very
likely win and those are the ones that
are going to be powering the rest of the
21st century